Hi everyone happy comic-con week. You probably just saw the news Marvel and ABC just
Cancelled agents of shield is gonna end after next season
They're finishing the last few episodes of season six right now
Season seven will have 13 episodes air next year. And then that's it. All the characters that don't die will permanently go to Tahiti
So without spilling any tea
I'll explain the story of why they're ending it now and how it lasted this long and behind the scenes Marvel drama and why you've
Never seen any of the TV characters make it into the movies
Spoiler warning for the spider-man far from home post credits scene in case you haven't seen spider-man far from home yet
But when you think about what Nick Fury is doing and what it means for Marvel phase 4
It'll make a little more sense how Marvel as a company Marvel Studios is transitioning away from earth-based stuff
So we'll break it all down if you're brand new to the channel
Be sure to subscribe to get all the comic-con videos is gonna be crazy
There's a new round of the IMAX ticket giveaway - all you have to do to enter is be a subscriber
And leave a Marvel comment on the video
I'll also explain what's going on with the timeline in the events of agents of shield right now between Avengers infinity war in Avengers endgame
Which is breaking down top-10 style number 10 rewind to the events of the original Avengers movie Joss
Whedon is hired after they've already started working on the movie
He's forced to do a rewrite of that while they're shooting around a couple big action scenes at the time Marvel Studios was still under
The control of Marvel CEO Isaac Perlmutter who is said to have been very hands-on and very difficult to work with
When Kevin Feige was trying to develop the Marvel Cinematic Universe now
This is around early Marvel phase 1 era heading into the first Avengers film long term
They solved that problem when Disney bought Marvel and then made Marvel Studios
Its own self-contained division giving Kevin Feige total control over the Marvel Cinematic Universe in the movies
They developed that didn't happen till right after Avengers age of Ultron
Tale and Marvel phase 2 so already they've done a whole bunch of films but 9 the original Avengers movie blew up at the box
Office huge like everyone expected and Marvel early on in their relationship
With Disney were making tons of money off of toy sales
But there was so much Marvel IP and characters going use the powers that be a Marvel and Disney wanted to start
Exploiting that through TV shows and create a TV division
If you can believe it most big studios earn more money on all their TV shows than they do on their movies
So naturally Marvel and Disney wanted to get on some of that action
But ate the creation of the TV division had nothing to do with Kevin Feige
He was off working on Avengers age of Ultron and developing the rest of the early Marvel phase 3 movies
Because the Marvel movies are the crown jewel of that brand Kevin Feige typically gets to decide where characters go
Is this a character that can go to a TV show or is this a character that can only be in the movies as you?
would expect all the most bankable big characters that have big toy sales big merchandise sellers all
Bookmarked for the movies only all the TV shows get to pick from the bargain bin in
Characters and ideas for stories that Kevin Feige said he probably never be interested in which is where you get to agents of shield
Because Kevin Feige was getting ready to destroy that organization in the MCU
So it wasn't gonna be around your okay fine make a TV show with that because we're not gonna be using it
We didn't had also killed off the Coulson character
So he was free to be used too
But very rare example of a movie character going onto the TV shows
Seven around that time Joss Whedon with the success of the first Avengers film was hired to a much bigger
Contract at Marvel to write and direct Avengers age of Ultron
to oversee all their Marvel films in phase 2 and phase 3 in a creative sense and
To develop TV shows because he comes from TV
The Buffyverse is one of the first things people usually remember him for so while Joss Whedon is developing Avengers age of Ultron
He also starts developing his first Marvel TV
Project which would become agents of shield that started right after the first Avengers movie hit theaters
6 you go 2 months later during the early stages of Avengers age of Ultron
Pre-production Kevin Feige in the Marvel producers are going back and forth with Joss Whedon on the details of the movie while that's happening
He starts talking to them about his agents of shield project
like I got this TV show that I'm developing in the way the Joss Whedon spills his tea in the most recent interview that he's
Done is that the powers that be at Marvel Studios the movie people weren't necessarily pissed off at him
That's probably not the right word for it
They kind of thought that the TV stuff that he was working on was a waste of time like why are you working on?
This TV show stuff when we really hired you to develop this multi-billion dollar movie Avengers age of Ultron
So already you're kind of getting the sense that the Marvel movie people are treating TV show stuff like a completely separate universe
They don't wanna have anything to do with it. They don't want to deal with it
But number 5
Disney and ABC
Wanted a Marvel show on the air so they were gonna make that agents of shield show no matter what the movie people wanted Joss
Whedon to do so Whedon was forced to stop being the showrunner in hand the project off to his younger brother
Jed Whedon and his wife who had previously worked with him on dollhouse and the other Whedon verse shows that he'd done so at this
Point he's totally checked out of the show in fully just focusing on movies stuff
That's why you know
Wait say like daredevil Luke Cage all the Netflix characters contractual cooling-off period ends and they start showing up an MCU projects
They'll probably be totally
Rebooted versions of the characters because Kevin Feige and the movie people clearly do not like dealing with stuff that they didn't originate
So whatever version of daredevil you see again is gonna be completely from the MCU people
For totally awesome guy Kevin Feige early on in the process also goes to Joss Whedon and tells him what they're doing in Captain America
Winter Soldier like you know what this agents of shield TV show idea you have is great
I'm sure you're having fun working on it
But you know, we're getting ready to destroy the basis for your TV show in our next movie
So we're sort of rendering your show pointless
Like why would you call it agents of shield if we're gonna blow up shield halfway through your first season
It doesn't make any sense all the TV show people working on the episodes had no idea that that was going to happen
Save for like one or two people at the top
So you start to see some of the problems they have in trying to do this connected universe and really why it wasn't meant to
Be connected in the first place three. That's why in later seasons
You saw the agents of shield people distancing themselves story wise from the MCU stuff. There were a few minor crossovers
never any real big a-list Avengers
I think Sam
Jackson's Nick Fury
Cameo during the first season for like a second is probably the biggest thing that they've ever done with a movie actor
But the movies never did anything with the TV characters, so it's a very one-sided relationship
So when talking about Captain America Civil War the writers Christopher Markus and Stephen
Fillie who'd been riding Marvel films all the way since the first Captain America films
They've been in the MCU doing movies for a long time
They said that at no point had they ever seen any episodes of agents of shield nor been
Asked to look at putting those characters in any of their movies
and so they also wore Avengers Infinity Ward Avengers endgame
so that's why you never saw any of the TV characters in the movies is because nobody
Working on any of the movies really cared at all about what was going on in the TV shows
Too during the early years the show is you all probably saw bombed in its first season on ABC critically
It was skating by it had a small audience and ABC wanted to make their money back that they've spent developing the show in order
To turn a profit TV shows typically need to do between 50 and 100 episodes
Most of that money now comes from streamers like Netflix who pay millions of dollars in licensing fees
So a lot of times even if a show gets really terrible ratings on TV
That would normally get it cancelled. If they know they're gonna make a lot of money from Netflix deals. They'll keep making the show
No matter how small it is, but because Disney is doing the Disney plus streaming service
they're gonna lose out on a lot of that licensing money because they're pulling all their
Content from Netflix and on to the Disney Plus streaming service
So one of the big nails in the coffin for Shield is the low ratings and now losing that Netflix deal heading into season five
ABC wanted to cancel the TV show knowing that this was going to happen
So that's why they wrote their season 5 finale
To coincide with Avengers infinity war in the snap so that they could give everyone a version of a happy ending
Then just snap everyone and it would be a really cool
WTF way to go out and to somewhat integrate with what's going on in the biggest Marvel movie of all time
After the fact though Disney put pressure on ABC to renew the show
So ABC was kind of backed into a corner and gave them two more seasons of 13 episodes per season
so that takes them through their season 7 in number 1
That's why after they sat down to discuss what they were gonna do for the story for next season on shield
They decided that they would do it as the final season. That way they can write all the episodes
Knowing that it's going to be the last they can kill off any characters that they want, but it doesn't
Necessarily mean that they're going to be doing any big movie crossovers
So I wouldn't expect any really big cameos from movie characters on agents of shield
Maybe outside chance of a Sam
Jackson cameo to sort of bookend his cameo from the first season
The other real big nail in the coffin for shield is also the Avengers TV shows that Kevin Feige in the Marvel Studios
People are developing
Hopefully that explains why they decided to cancel the show and why it's lasted this long and why there haven't been any big movie
Crossovers in terms of timeline the stuff that's happening on agents of shield right now
This season is happening a year after the snap and Avengers infinity war in nowhere on the show
Have they really referenced the snap or talked about any of that stuff?
So clearly they're trying to avoid all the movie stuff full-on at this point
What'll probably happen is is I'll do a video for the eventual finale because it has been on for seven seasons
They've done a couple cool things. The Ghost Rider character is getting a spinoff TV show on Hulu
So if you really like Ghost Rider on agents of shield
He's getting his own show pretty soon
The big Marvel phase four panel is happening Saturday night, but there's even more trailers dropping tomorrow on Fridays
I'm posting this video as long as you have alerts enabled for my channel
you should see all the videos when I post them and I have a bookmark at the top of my youtube channel with all the
Comic Con videos that I'm posting so you should see all the videos there too. Even if you don't get the alerts
Congratulations to the giveaway winner from my last big video Sean the man won. Please email me on the about page of my channel
So I can get your details
click here for that brand new Thor Ford teaser and click here for my Avengers and game deleted scenes and
Blu-ray bonus features video. Thank you so much for watching. Everybody. Stay awesome. Happy Comic Con week